الهجوم على سد نوفا كخوفكا ياتي بينما
تسعى اوكرانيا جاهده للعثور على ثغره في
الدفاعات الروسيه لذا كففت استهدافها عبر
الاستهدافات المباشره صحيفه تيلغراف
البريطانيه اشارت الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تواصل شن هجمات متزامنه في
خمسه اتجاهات على الاقل في منطقه دنيا شرق
اوكرانيا مسؤول اوكرانيا قال لي ان الجيش
يقوم بعمليات للبحث عن نقاط ضعف في الخطوط
الروسيه الا انه لم يؤكد بدء الهجوم
المضاد وفي الاسابيع الاخيره شنت اوكرانيا
سلسله من الهجمات بما في ذلك غارات وضربات
بمسيارات داخل روسيا حتى وصلت الى موسكو
الى العاصمه بهدف اختبار دفعات روسيا قبل
ذلك كانت مصادر مخابرات غربيه توقعت ان
تزج اوكرانيا باثني عشر لواء هجوميا جديدا
تم التدريب تسعه منها من قبل النيتو بمجرد
اكتشاف اي فجوه في دفاعات روسيا وان تكون
الهجمات المتقطعه مقدمه للهجوم المضاده من
الهجمات الاوكرانيه ما تم شنه باستخدام
اسلحه قدمها الغرب نتحدث طبعا عن الهجوم
بصواريخ ستورم شادو البريطانيه على مراكز
لوجستيه وايضا مراكز قياده خلف خطوط
الجبهه ايضا تحدثت مصادر عسكريه روسيه عن
رصد دباباتي
ومدرعات فرنسيه في ساحه المعركه ما يشير
الى انضمام القوات التي دربها الناتو الى
الخطوط الاماميه لاول مره منذ بدء هذه
الحرب كما رصدت اقمار صناعيه عسكريه
امريكيه ارتفاعا طفيفا في الضربات
المدفعيه وايضا في الهجمات البريه من
المواقع الاوكرانيه من الجانب الاخر
مشاهدينا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
احبط هجوما واسع النطاق من ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتين للدبابات جنوب دانياسك
الناطق باسم الوزاره ايغور كوناشنكوف قال
ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت اختراق مع
اعتبرته اكياف الجزء الاكثر ضعفا في
الجبهه الا ان الهجوم لم ينجح بحسب قوله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات